bonjour à tous bienvenue à strasbourg au
parlement européen c'est parti pour 30
minutes d'actualité européenne alors que
l'euro de foot démarre nous allons nous
poser la question des enjeux de cette
compétition comment assurer sa sécurité
quelles sont les retombées économiques à
attendre et comment ceci peut-il
travailler à améliorer la citoyenneté
européenne avant d'en débattre avec mes
invités il y a quelques jours un
français a été arrêté avec un véritable
arsenal à la frontière ukraino polonaise
reposant de nouveau la question de la
sécurisation de cette compétition on
écoute
ce tournoi 625 kg de tnt 29 lance
grenades
vous pouvez imaginer quel type de
destructions et de perte en vie humaine
cela peut causer un véritable arsenal il
y a quelques jours un jeune français
inconnu des services de police a été
arrêté à la frontière entre l'ukraine et
la pologne empêchant ainsi 15 attentats
planifiés avant et pendant leur football
selon les services de sécurité
ukrainiens
le jeune homme s'opposerait à la
politique du gouvernement à l'arrivée
massive d'étrangers en france à la
diffusion de l'islam et de la
mondialisation il comptait visaient des
mosquées des synagogues des centres des
impôts et des autoroutes
une information non confirmée par la
france qui privilégie la piste du trafic
d'armes
c'est le premier coup de semonce sur la
sécurité de l'euro de football
un enjeu de taille pour le ministère de
l'intérieur
des commandos qui viennent jusqu'à nous
serons peu en difficulté pour passer à
l'acte s'ils ne parviennent pas à
acquérir les armes à feu qui leur
permettent de passer à l'acte donc il
est absolument fondamental que nous
puissions avoir sur ce sujet une action
coordonnée des pays de l'union
européenne y compris en étant en
situation de mieux contrôler par les
services dont c'est la compétence ce qui
se passe sur internet en matière de
trafic d'armes
c'est là un enjeu considérable plus de
2,5 millions de spectateurs sont
attendus dont un million de visiteurs
étrangers pour cette édition de l'euro
une gageur pour les services de sécurité
qui face aux menaces d'attentats ont
préféré organiser de nombreuses fans
zone dont certaines accueilleront près
de 95 mille spectateurs
nous avons décidé de faire une feinte
zone parce que il
mieux contenir effectivement l'événement
et avant à rome une concentration de
personnes avec un système sécurisé
plutôt que d'avoir des dieux un peu
partout dans paris qui se montrent de
façon plus anarchique et qui serait plus
difficilement contrôlable assurer la
sécurité
cela a un coût 24 millions d'euros rien
que pour ses fans zone soit 14 millions
d'euros supplémentaires
côté stade la facture a augmenté de 15%
une ardoise bien lourde qui rogne le
bénéfice attendu sur l'économie
française de 1,24 milliard d'euros
alors peut-on garantir la sécurité de
cet euro de football c'est la question
que je vais poser à mes invités alain
cadec bonjour bonjour bienvenue vous
êtes député européen français et vous
êtes membre du groupe populaire européen
donc les républicains en france à côté
de vous marc tarabella bonjour bonjour
vous êtes belge vous êtes supporters des
diables rouges donc bien évidemment bien
évidemment qu'on crée la surprise
bah écoute et on verra ça et vous êtes
député socialiste au sein de ce
parlement socialiste démocrate et vous
coprésider l'intergroupe sport oui voilà
alors messieurs est ce qu'on peut
garantir la sécurité de cet euro alain
cadec je vouvoyais hochait la tête
pendant le sujet sur ses fans zone est
ce que c'est une bonne idée
moi je suis très inquiet sur les fans
zone je pense que dans les stades
ça ne devrait pas poser de problème
majeur il ya un système bien organisé de
contrôle qui a été renforcé d'ailleurs à
l'occasion de cet euro par contre le
principe des fans zone me semble très
compliqué à agir et et organisant terme
c'est qu'il y ait un vous voulez dire en
termes sécuritaires
je pense que on aurait dû organiser les
fans zone ailleurs d'ailleurs dans des
endroits facilement sécurisable des
stades
il existe des stades à paris qui sont
pas utilisés qui charléty part et
d'autre un à plusieurs dans la région
parisienne wire pour organiser ses fans
zone parce que là on peut contrôler
c'est une enceinte fermée c'est plus
facile alors que là on va se retrouver
dans des espaces ouverts et énorme mars
à paris le champ de mars l'esplanade des
invalides où il y aura énormément de
monde difficile à contrôler et donc ça
me paraît on vous le conseille et pas en
fait à nos téléspectateurs d'aller dans
les femmes je ne conseille pas en tous
les cas je pense qu'il ya un risque
certain maintenant c'est vrai qu'à une
psychose de l'attentât mais aujourd'hui
on sait pourquoi marc tarabella vous
êtes d'accord
finalement les fans zone ça sert pas à
grand chose si on veut garantir l'effet
que j'ai pas dit que ça ne servait pas à
grand chose et moi qui le dit
je vois pas très bien l'intérêt mais je
ne sais pas les gens quand ils ont une
charte du danemark qui viennent ils
doivent obliger d'aller dans la fanzone
ou pas non ils peuvent aller aux champs
elysées finalement ils font un peu ce
qui valorise 100 mais j'imagine bien aux
touristes qui vient de l'étranger
il ya des grands écrans quatre coins de
l'europe qui vient à voir sans écrit son
équipe il a envie d'aller sur les
champs-elysées alors vous marc tarabella
avec votre écharpe des diables rouges
vous est récent mais les fans zone ont
leur intérêt mais il faut que ce soit
sécurisé on a le même problème en
belgique il ya des écrans géants
les communes doivent déclarer si elles
font des matches sur écran géant au site
elle cafetiers ou tel tenancier le fait
ou tel club de foot parce que ça risque
d'amener beaucoup de personnes au même
endroit et donc forcément ça augmente le
risque
personnellement je préfère regarder
match de foot avec des amis dans un
bistrot ou dans le village mais met donc
là le risque zéro finalement n'existe
pas quel que soit le nombre de crs
il n'existe jamais mais il faut essayer
de limiter le succès engendre vers zéro
et là c'est pas le cas à mon avis les
autorités ont quand même mis beaucoup
moins fort pour des moyens pour d'abord
pour les contrôles pour les stades
l'accès au stade
il ya des soucis je pense à un jeu il
n'y a pas de souci dans le stade
probablement à l'extérieur la wii 6 1 ab
s'il vient avec les bourgs et dynamité
qui ce fait exploser deux et qui a 500
personnes autour de lui ça peut être un
carnage à l'extérieur du stade donc là
il y aura des regroupements en bas il
faut éviter la psychose c'est vrai
l'euro est une fête
ça doit rester une fête vous pensez
encore que une fête est possible vu le
contexte s'il ne fait était pas possible
de dire qu'on renonce et que le recevant
la barbarie heureusement que la fête est
possible et la fête elle existera
pendant l'euro enfin je le souhaite en
tous les cas nous souhaitons tous l'euro
c'est la fête du foot en europe s'est
scellée grand moment attendu
donc oui il y aura la fête sûrement
maintenant il faut limiter les risques
qui pourraient transformer cette fête en
drame
alors on parle du risque d'attentats
mais on sait qu'il ya aussi le risque
hooligan est ce qu'on peut véritablement
contrôler aussi
ces supporters qui risquerait de petit
peu s'accrocher dans les fan zone wire
d'ailleurs moi je pense que ce problème
a quand même été résolus notamment par
les britanniques les anglais notamment
qui ont résolu ce problème il ya très
longtemps parce qu'ils ont été les plus
victimes parce que leurs supporters
surtout à l'extérieur du pays était
insupportable
souvenons nous du sl 85 quand même une
trentaine d'années mais clairement je
pense que c'est bon enfant
on les supporters les deux des deux
équipes nationales j'ai rarement vu de
heurts entre supporters de l'équipe
nationale
je pense aussi que le hooliganisme a
considérablement diminué
cela étant il ya encore quelques
groupuscules manipuler aussi un petit
peu qui pourrait profiter de cette
situation de l'euro pour pour provoquer
des affrontements des choses comme ça
mais je pense que la police française
est bien organisé pour à noyauter ces
groupes là et est bien organisé pour
éviter ce genre de d'événements phares
quand on voit que bernard cazeneuve a
pointé le problème européen du contrôle
des armes avec ce jeune homme donc de 25
ans qui a été arrêté à la frontière
entre l'ukraine et la pologne avec un
véritable arsenal est ce que l'europe
est globalement prête à ce genre de
menaces
marc tarabella on s'y prépare parce que
ce qui s'est passé là-bas il y avait 120
kilos de tnt
je ne connais pas du tout le prix du
marché du thé ntm est donc ce type a
consacré une fortune pour acheter de
l'armement est donc clairement on doit
mettre les moyens et on a chaque pays a
mis les moyens il conviendrait qu on les
met plus qu on n'échange plus ces
données au niveau européen on nous a
bassiné ce parlement européen pour voter
le pnr le qui ont bassiné très bien
voilà vos clés mais c'est pas ça le
problème
le problème c'est que les états ne
s'échangent pas les donner je rappelle
que ça la vraie slam a été contrôlé
trois fois en france après les attentats
de paris et les revenus en belgique qui
s'est planqué on n'a pas retrouvé
on l'a retrouvé quelques mois après est
ce normal non il était pourtant signalé
chez europol mais si on ne consulte pas
les bases de données ça ne sert à rien
collecter si on ne se donne pas les
moyens d'analyser les données c'est au
gouvernement ensemble à faire les
efforts qu'il faut au niveau européen
mais arrêtons de taper sur l'europe sur
le parlement européen et les
gouvernements qui aujourd'hui sont la
cause de la paralysie européenne unsa
plus entendre je pense que le pnr était
indispensable était nécessaire mais il
n'est pas suffisant comme des marques il
a raison il faut absolument qu'il ya un
échange des données entre les différents
états c'est indispensable
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas ou pas
toujours ou pas ou pas assez en tous les
cas et c'est absolument nécessaire
il aurait fallu que ce soit une
obligation
ce soit une obligation et bernard
cazeneuve qui pointe en fait la faillite
de l'europe dans le contrôle du trafic
d'armes
c'est facile est facile de pointer à tel
ou untel sur le trafic d'armes sur ceci
ou sur ceux là on peut tous points
terreur le cto l'europe est toujours
responsable de tout bernard cazeneuve le
dit d'autres l'ont dit avant lui mais
c'est trop facile ça oui bon c'est une
chose dont l'europe ne sera peut-être
pas responsables c'est du prix 1 2 7
euros
on s'est beaucoup posé en france la
question des stades les stades qui ont
été rénovés pour pouvoir accueillir
l'euro est justement à ce propos louis
sybille et virginie parrot se sont
rendus à marseille pour voir un petit
peu la facture du nouveau stade
vélodrome direction orange vélodrome
d'orange vélodrome effectivement avec le
naming
il a été rebaptisé donc direction le
stade orange vélodrome
ce soir une saison s'achève
c'est la finale de la coupe de france et
son derby mythique paris contre
marseille mais dans cette dernière ligne
droite avant l'euro 2016 se joue un
autre match stade de france versus le
nouveau stade vélodrome avant
l'olympique de marseille on était jaloux
donc pas du stade de france mais du parc
des princes qui au delà de ce qu'on peut
dire était un vrai stade de foot et
envoyait ça vraiment comme quelque chose
qu'on n'avait pas à marseille si on
avait un stade ouvert aux quatre vents
elle en avait la situation s'inverser
avec un stade vélodrome qui est devenu
un vrai stade de foot maintenant qu'il
est couvert qu'il ya une bonne ambiance
on a vu ça l'an dernier mais non ce qui
est totalement retombé cette année vu
les résultats catastrophiques de
l'équipe
le vélodrome le stade emblématique de
marseille a subi un gros lifting pour
l'euro 2016
cette nuit place de plus et un nouveau
toit blanc à base de thé faux l'addition
s'annonce salée 268 millions d'euros
ces 100 millions de plus qu'annoncé au
début des travaux la moitié est payée
par les pouvoirs publics
l'autre par arema une filiale de
bouygues c'est un partenariat public
privé
un choix judicieux selon la mairie car
l'investissement reste rentable
tout le roux ici à marseille les quatre
matches qui vont se jouer
ils ont rapporté 180 millions d'euros de
retombées par la restauration par le la
vente dans les commerces par les hôtels
et donc tout ça participe au
développement économique de la vie des
retombées économiques certes seulement
la question ne s'arrête pas là pendant
31 ans la ville de marseille va devoir
payer une redevance à arema qui de son
côté prend en charge l'entretien du
stade ont tous le coût réel net s'élève
à 500 millions d'euros
jean-jacques purito a suivi la faire
pour le journal la provence
pour lui les travaux auraient dû
commencer bien avant ça fait un mort ça
parce que ça n'était pas si vieux que ça
ce stade avait été rénové en 1995 pour
la coupe du monde donc ce stade à 20
heures et 21 c'est pas mieux pour le
stade mais je trouve que cannes valeur
rénové bien on a oublié des choses qui
paraissent essentiels sur lesquels ne
s'est pas trompé chez comme le toit du
stade il fallait pas les ip il fallait
il fallait l'améliorer à tout point de
vue pour la circulation pour le pour la
sécurité des hommes à leur faire
certains marseillais ont vu toutes les
métamorphoses du vélodrome scène de 95
et les précédentes
rené malleville est l'un des plus
fidèles supporters de l'om c'est le
troisième est stable que je connais
depuis que je supporte l'om je le tague
qu'on va le payer pour réduire les
dépenses
la ville compte augmenter lourdement le
loyer du stade au club l'olympique de
marseille
un loyer négocier à 4 millions d'euros
hors de prix alors que cette année a été
catastrophique pour l'om ne pas s'être
année pour une finale au club le paris
saint-germain moi je suis chez hp
d'analystes journal et coups de gueule
de rené malleville sont bien connus sur
internet ils s'enregistrent dans ce
sujet après chaque match un joueur moyen
avec un bon joueur moyen avec à 4
millions d'euros on a eu de quoi tous
les amants se priver d'un bon joueur
moyen comprenait pas pourquoi parce
qu'il faut les filets à la ville de
marseille
les travaux ont été engagés pour que le
vélodrome devienne un stade 5 étoiles
selon les normes de l'uefa
c'était l'une des conditions pour que la
france puisse accueillir l'euro 2016
l'opposition souhaitait que ce soit
uniquement le privé qui les prennent en
charge
où le stade appartient à la ville de
marseille
et elle fait une réhabilitation modestes
comme on aurait pu le faire pour environ
80 millions d'euros ou le stade
appartient au club ou à des privés a
souvent là c'est leur problème mais le
partenariat public privé c'est toujours
entre les deux le stade vélodrome n'est
qu'un exemple pour l'euro 2016 quatre
stades ont été construits de toutes
pièces cinq ont été rénovés la facture
s'élèverait à 2,5 milliards d'euros
selon certaines études l'euro 2016
devrait relancer l'économie française de
seulement 1,2 milliard d'euros
le compte n'y est toujours pas
le compte n'y est toujours pas marc
tarabella 500 millions d'euros sur 30
ans alors ce stade vélodrome ce stade
vélodrome orange c'est ça puisqu'ils du
coup il a été renommé du coup la facture
est absolument astronomique on a les
moyens de se payer un euro pareil la
facture astronomique ce qui m'étonne
toujours c'est que le prix à l'arrivée
est largement différent de celui
escompté au départ ça je ne comprends
pas parce que j'ai l'impression que ce
qui peut paraître intéressant le
partenariat public-privé et moi je
considère de plus en plus que c'est une
socialisation des pertes et de
l'investissement et une privatisation
des bénéfices et donc il ya quand même
abandonné un jeu de dupes et le privé
rarement d'ubs dans l'histoire est donc
effectivement ça peut être un peu chéro
comme investissement ça servira aux
supporters de l'om après un superbe
stade évidemment il faut penser à ceux
qui vont marche départ après l'important
c'est évidemment là les retombées
économiques pour toute la france et
l'organisation d'un événement comme
l'euro a des retombées économiques et il
faut l'espérer dans le secteur horeca
dans d'antan dans les cafés les
restaurants dans l'achat de biens divers
donc un épisode d'une vitrine formidable
aussi donc il ne faut pas le nier
maintenant c'est vrai que la facture de
l'investissement est peut-être trop
importants par rapport aux retombées
escomptées
vous êtes d'accord alain cadec le
partenariat public privé d'abord je
pense qu'il ya des critères qui sont
imposées par l'uefa aux pour la fifa sur
les stades
des critères précis qu'il faut respecter
pour pouvoir justement concourir à
l'euro par ailleurs je pense que sans le
partenariat public privé
il y aurait pas eu ce stade tous
simplement parce que les collectivités
n'aurait pas eu les moyens de les
construire donc je pense que ce
partenariat public privé
il est nécessaire il est même
obligatoire donc moi je considère que ce
sont des opérations évidemment je
rejoins un marc tarabella cieux qui au
bout du compte coûte beaucoup d'argent
sans doute plus cher que ce qui était
prévu au départ mais qui sont à mon avis
indispensable
on voit bien à lyon on voit bien dans
les autres à bordeaux on voit bien que
le tout nouveau stade à nice aussi où le
nouveau stade a été a été rénové grâce
au pot partenariat public public privé
je pense qu on n'y serait pas arrivé
autrement mais parce qu'on n'a pas les
moyens finalement de se payer 7 euros
aujourd'hui les collectivités locales et
les collectivités territoriales sans vie
de france n'ont pas les moyens très
clair je préside une collectivité
territoriale je sais ce que c'est on est
incapable de payer un stade c'est clair
mais si on a les retombées qui se ferait
approximativement 1,25 milliard d'euros
et un coût ne serait ce que des stades
et des investissements et des
infrastructures qui se monte à 2 5
milliards est ce qu'à un moment la
balance est pas un peu c'est des
équipements sur ce pour le long terme
oui parce que c'est exact les
équipements qui sont faits pour
plusieurs générations enfants tous les
cas j'espère et puis donc donc ça va
servir pendant 25 30 ans 40 ans donc il
faut quand même le mettre sur la durée
et qui va nous coûter cher en loyer pour
le coup d'accord sur investissement pour
le long terme
c'est vrai que il n'ya pas que les
stades ya surtout des infrastructures au
6e tour ce sont des infrastructures en
termes de mobilité à certains endroits
par exemple dans une veine par exemple
que ça puisse servir après aux habitants
tant mieux comme un village on a une fin
la dynamique en fait selon vous le fait
d'accueillir un euro de foot comme
d'accueillir les jeux olympiques
je tiens ta belgique mais moi je me
souviens que nous sommes vous êtes dans
la même configuration que la france 98
une belle équipe avec un entraîneur qui
a du cran pour écarter certains bons
joueurs comme l'a fait aimé jacquet car
je rappelle qu'aimé jacquet a écarté
cantona et ginola et les champions du
monde ben deschamps a eu ce cran il ya
une polémique mais j'espère que la
france ira loin
parce que cette équipe le mérite et
l'entraîneur également sur le diable
rouge mais parce qu'ils ont pris tous
les meilleurs joueurs belges et qui joue
d'ailleurs pour la plupart en première
league en angleterre mais en tous les
cas je pense que marc une mode c'est de
faire la meilleure équipe possible
bon donc en fait finalement cette
polémique sur les stades quand la france
aura gagné on leur a très bien mais je
pense que en 98 c'est vrai on avait mis
beaucoup d'argent dans les stades aussi
on remet beaucoup d'argent dans les
stades mais est-ce que vous allez au
stade régulièrement il ya vingt vingt
mille trente mille quarante mille
spectateurs des familles qui vous qu'ils
sont heureux a le taux de remplissage
moyen c'est 77% on les remplit pas ses
considérables
le taux de rendement d'une éolienne
c'est 30%
rien à voir mais rien à voir je le passe
quand même obligé une tristesse parce
que mon club français préféré c'est le
fc nantes et on le jouera par la
beaujoire qui avait été créé pour l'euro
bon ben vous voyez mais alors il ya une
autre polémique un key qui a un petit
peu aussi agacer certains pourfendeurs
de des fonds publics c'est que l'uefa
dans son cahier des charges pour obtenir
l'euro de football demande une
exonération fiscale et je n'ai pas la
première fois ça veut dire que en gros
l'uefa ne paiera pas d'impôt sur ce
qu'elle gagnera en france pendant 7
euros est ce que c'est bien normal
alain cadec non mais sur le principe sur
le principe non bien sûr mais
aujourd'hui c'est dans le ticket
d'entrée
donc si on veut l'euro on n'acceptait
pas très moral comme ticket d'avancé
tout à fait à moral donc que l'uefa ait
les grandes entreprises multinationales
élus de l'impôt il y en a marre ce
parlement a voté une résolution cette
semaine pour dire on doit arrêter
l'évasion fiscale surtout des grandes
entreprises quand le petit menuisier ou
maçon ou la coiffeuse du coin pesson
impôts que le travailleur paie son impôt
que l'employé paix sont un poète les
grandes multinationales sous prétexte
qu'elles viennent créer de l'emploi chez
nous ne payent pas d'impôts
c'est ta morale et l'uefa deux
structures qui est plein de pognon la
fifa encore plus ces gens doivent
participer à l'effort et on pourrait
ainsi les faire contribuer à la
construction des stades et pas toujours
le citoyen payeur
oui non mais je suis complètement
d'accord dire que l'uefa ou la fifa sont
des organismes qui ont beaucoup d'argent
alors en plus leur accorder des
facilités c'est vrai que c'est exagéré
crise exagéré sur les temps c'était dans
le ticket d'entrée donc il fallait que
la france accepte cela étant je ne
partage pas non plus je pense que c'est
pas la première fois
quant aux à chaque fois mais l'uefa
pourrait très bien payé la tva
évidemment quelles possibilités on a
politiquement de peser sur le f à
pourvoir ce règlement c'est une culture
qui est quand même j'ai quand même du
respect pour l'uefa que j'avais moi pour
la fifa pourquoi parce que là l'uefa
je suis co président de l'intergroupe du
sport chaque fois qu'on organisait des
événements pour parler des critères
d'attribution des grands événements
sportifs et autres et du fair play
financier de tous les dossiers
l'uefa est présence aux stratégies drame
ce silverstein vient au parlement
européen
ils sont présents la fifa s'est débiné à
deux reprises et est donc maintenant
j'espère qu'elle va progresser la
nouvelle gouvernance la fifa donc non
mais on rappelle qu'il ya effectivement
des scandales de corruption de dessous
de table qui ont été révélés je peux
citer platini aussi parce que l'euro
2020 et on n'a déjà pas fait le
2016-2020 ap le faire dans toute
l'europe
c'est une idée géniale tient en termes
de fédérations unités de platini platini
est clairement il faut rendre hommage je
verrai à cette idée qui a bien
fonctionné et qui est passé dans l'union
a désigné les stades des villes
je crois que c'est quelque chose de
fondamental l'uefa un rôle fédérateur il
ya des défauts mais n'oublions le jetons
pas le bébé avec l'eau du bain
il ya aussi l'organisation de
compétitions telles que l'action
publique que l'europa league qui
mériterait d'être valorisé d'ailleurs
parce que souvent un peu dévalorisés par
rapport à la chaîne que le syli
et puis au niveau des compétitions
nationales le chante l'euro de foot
c'est un événement depuis 1960
alors justement la transition est toute
trouvée puisque vous évoquez le levier
pour les citoyens européens de se
reconnaître en fait dans l'euro de foot
dans leurs équipes dans leur nation
alors on sait justement poser la
question chez dans le think tank pardon
sport et citoyenneté qui a été voir un
petit peu tous les sportifs que compte
la france qui se sont qui se sont donc
exprimés sur cette citoyenneté
européenne donc est ce que le foot peut
être un levier pour cette citoyenneté et
l'euro a fortiori on écoute
comme attaquant milieu de terrain
défenseur chacun sa place chacun son
rôle en europe
j'espère toujours que ma mère l'a
compris en europe nous sommes unis dans
notre diversité nous sommes riches que
nos différences
en europe nous sommes unis par
l'atmosphère et pour gagner il faut
jouer collectif
nous sommes liés par leur et chez les
autres la tolérance et le dortoir
nous sommes unis pour notre ami mais
sans élite pour gagner l'europe est une
communauté sportive et citoyenne de
différence entre nous mais une passion
de gagner mais en europe nous sommes 500
millions de citoyens concernés par le
sport d'euros plus 11 juillet dans nos
valeurs de respect et d'égalité aux
idéaux de paix et de liberté
en europe nous avons des cultures
différentes
nous avons des systèmes de jeu
différents donc ça nous unit dans la
différence nous sommes ensemble dans la
diversité
aujourd'hui l'europe s'apprête à fédérer
500 millions de citoyens
demain les vibreurs sont vos exploits la
différence est une richesse
la différence est une richesse
différence est une richesse sont
multiples nous sommes l'avenir nous
sommes européens
la différence est une richesse nous
sommes multiples sommes l'avenir nous
sommes l'europe
alors ça paraît très beau comme ça mais
alors qu'est-ce que oui oui c'est plutôt
nous sommes unis dans la diversité c'est
donc plutôt sympathique mais comment est
ce que on peut utiliser ce levier qu'est
l'euro de foot quand on sait à quelques
semaines du break type de référendum
britannique pour la sortie ou le
maintien dans l'union européenne comment
est-ce qu'on peut utiliser le football
et les valeurs du football pour
travailler un peu cette citoyenneté
éventuellement en éliminant l'angleterre
au premier tour ah oui d'accord
la solution non non je crois
malheureusement que cela ne pèsera pas
sur la décision des citoyens
britanniques bien sûr mais cela étant
c'est un catalyseur pour pour les
peuples européens bien entendu le
football c'est quelque chose d'universel
donc évidemment c'est européen je dire
cc oui mais qu'est ce qu'on en fait en
fait de cette compétition c'est à dire
qu'on capitalise jamais quand on est
député européen sur le fait que l'euro
de foot bas c'est quelque chose qui
représente chez les européens
sait on s'en sert donc aussi que parce
que le 1 euro de foot quand évidemment
les supporters sont de vrais supporters
c'est un moment de convivialité et au
parlement européen par exemple chaque
soir il ya des contents et des
mécontents
ouais le lendemain ça alimente les
discussions les gens se mettent leur
drapeau national ou un tee-shirt où il
est on sait à quel point il ya beaucoup
de supporters de foot dans stahl et non
clair évidemment mais au delà du
parlement c'est les citoyens et donc le
fait de d'avoir cette compétition qui
fait qu'ils regardaient pas non
seulement par l'europe par le monde
entier mais au niveau européen qu'anti
les valeurs de respect de solidarité son
véhicule et le think tank de sport et
citoyenneté avec monsieur laurent tulle
notamment je salue font un travail
formidable par rapport à ça par rapport
à l'intégration dans la société par le
sport ils ont notamment une initiative
avec le football de kraainem près de
bruxelles où tous les mercredis après
midi ce sont des que des réfugiés des
jeunes réfugiés qui viennent jouer les
installations sont mises à disposition
c'est le s et kraainem avec m
excuse moi mais même au niveau national
il ya eu des critiques une des choses
qui ont été dites mais aujourd'hui
l'équipe de france le football c'est
quoi ces black blanc beur qu'on le
veuille ou qu'on le veuille ou pas oui
c'est aussi là où tout le monde se
retrouve
mais ça c'est une question identitaire
mais plus globalement sur ceux des
densités européenne qui se retrouvent
dans cet euro justement parce qu'on
trouve comme disait marc le supporters
se retrouvent ils font la fête ensemble
un faux pas le délitement est dû à ce
que l'europe avait intuit n'est plus
gérable
il faut le dire clairement il ya plus de
tabous elle n'est plus gérable parce que
les règles n'ont pas évolué en fonction
du lot ou grandissante pays n'est pas
gérable dans la façon dont elle est
gérée à l'est actuellement et peut être
gérables pas si c'est parce que 28 pays
où des minorités peuvent dire non ne le
fait pas on ne participe pas et
aujourd'hui on a un peu l'impression que
certains pays sont là pour se servir de
l'europe comme d'un distributeur
automatique de billets mais pas pour
partager les problèmes et ça et va
falloir régler ce problème en moment
donné on est dans l'europe pour partager
le royaume uni n'a jamais fait ça depuis
le début ils ont un statut spécial
depuis le début j'ai aucun état d'âme
moi non plus c'est dommage mais si
l'équipe c'est plus grave pour eux pour
nous oui
donc en gros ça veut dire que si on les
élimine au premier tour bah tant pis
s'ils sortent le 23 selon vous si on
fait la grâce dont les illumine au
premier tour et si le break 6 passes
m'annoncer pas que c'est pas la
catastrophe on s'en sortira bon eh bien
écoutez ce sera le mot de la fin
en attendant on a entendu vos pronostics
et puis bah rendez vous le mois prochain
pour voir dans ce milieu duquel finale
le 10 juillet le 18 avec une belle
victoire de la france avec une belle
victoire de la france et deux et trois
heures et 3 0 mais écoutez monsieur
merci ça ne m'étonne pas merci beaucoup
bien entendu merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis cet euro donc des marrons se
retrouvera bien entendu le mois prochain
pour faire le bilan en attendant vous
retrouvez ahmed tazir la semaine
prochaine bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires ciao
oh